[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là les lauriers du poste
qu'il a regardé tout ce qui s'est passé
bien sûr il va remettre ses trophées
comme chaque soir et il ya eu du lourd
hier soir j'ai beaucoup de choses à la
télé vous kouchner soirée télé c'était
un petit peu quand benjamin castaldi
avec ces familles avaient du choix ouais
ouais
attention vous plus loin c'est bon ça y
avait notamment sur ces vies de touche
pas à mon kenji qui sera le gros morceau
de la chronique bien entendu dans
quelques instants
né sur france 2 dont vous n'avez parlé à
quelques minutes il y avait un prime
time que personne n'attendait à part
delphine ernotte la patronne de france
télévisions le grand oral qui sera le
meilleur orateur c'est ouf c'est un
concours d'éloquence
alors dire je suis très étonné qu'il
n'ait pas proposé à jean michel maire
d'être dans le jour qui aurait été la
mode des jeux je pense alors on a dormi
pendant deux heures cinquante démission
et moment de la conclusion un des
membres du jury s'est lancé dans un
monologue incroyable et ça m'a rappelé
quelqu'un vous allez voir je remets donc
à bertrand perrier le laurier du gars
qui s'emballe un peu trop en conclusion
de l'émission où tout le monde s'est
fait iech
[Musique]
quel bonheur que cette soirée pour ceux
qui aiment les mots qui aiment la parole
qui parfois en font profession
quel bonheur de voir enfin cette
éloquence mise à l'honneur à 20h50 sur
le service public
quel magnifique mission et c'est
fantastique d'avoir enfin cette mise à
l'honneur et donc j'espère que c'est le
début de quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
mais les sympathiques et d'aller mais
moi ce mec là il était comment est mince
mais deux heures et demie qui tenait
avec une requête 12e donc il a enchaîné
invite évidemment cette émission de
notre ami le surdoué marc-antoine le
bret pour faire des imitations grand
oral malheureusement pour lui il s'est
retrouvé face à roselyne bachelot c'est
qui fait de la politique juste pour
passer à la télé et je revêts donc à
marc-antoine le bret le laurier du gars
qui étaient tranquillement venus faire
une imitation et qui est tombé sur une
bonne relou
roselyne bachelot qu'est ce qui est le
plus important dans l'expression orale
pour vous l'exploitation alors cette
anémie que je pose la question oui c'est
moi oui je suis là bonjour nous mais
vous militaires ont milité très bon bah
je vous en parle
[Applaudissements]
dans cette émission on a fait la
connaissance de mounir arrivée l'homme
qui participait au concours d'éloquence
en fait - il passe ses journées à
réciter des poèmes qui l'écrit lui-même
le problème c'est que les poèmes les
garde pas pour lui il aider clame à ses
clients dans le bus qui conduit paris et
tous les gens qui prennent le bus à
paris ils veulent pas entendre des rimes
pour ils veulent juste rentrer chez eux
alors voici le laurier du chauffeur qui
ferait mieux de conduire son bus plutôt
que de se prendre pour arthur rimbaud le
chrome os
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
à paris ou le présent et le passé se
mêlent dans cette grande scène
intemporel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à vous lire ouais j'ai vraiment mounir
hambaoui mounir hulu et et vous qu'au
volant au ska côté du boulodrome où les
socialistes ont déposé des sacs et
chaque fois je la regarde et me fais ok
c'est bon cette vanne ça va donc se
poursuivre alors il est temps de passer
à votre prime d'hier soir cyril
évidemment touche pas à mon kenjy parce
que hier vous avez eu la chance de faire
un duo avec angie ouais ça c'est beau
quand même alors le truc c'est que même
avec le karaoké vous aviez beaucoup de
mal avec les paroles avaient écouté les
bras bien mais franchement ces paroles
je n'arrive pas à me mettre dans la tête
ça c'est un petit peu vu ouais ensuite
on va dire que vous chantiez ce que vous
pouviez quoi c'est ce qui sortait alors
emporté donc le laurier du gars qui
prouve qu'on peut être le meilleur
animateur du monde mais aussi le pire
chanteur du monde à tabac chaque fois
[Musique]
quand anthony faire qu'en forme était
déjà tout
[Musique]
ah les râper la partie de soprano et on
va découvrir que vous avez un flou entre
mano et benny b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et là je pense qu alger il essayait toi
et toi c'est en tout cas merci d'avoir
été aussi nombreux à suivre ce prime
merci c'est vrai et alors dans touche
pas à mon poste on sait tous qui a une
grande tradition depuis neuf ans
s'élance et les musiques au mauvais
moment où ne pas lancer les musiques du
tout et bien hier dès le début du prime
cécile lance un petit megamix des plus
grands tubes de kenji ouais c'était
magnifique mais comme d'habitude
personne ne vous écoute alors aussi le
laurier du seul dj au monde qui n'a pas
envie de lancer un seul disque
[Musique]
bien mon kenji merci d'être là mon kenji
candidature aubry
[Applaudissements]
alors si l'on sait que l'anglais et vous
c'est comme vincent cerutti et
l'animation télé ça fait de lui un
bâtard non j'enchaîne alors en revanche
est totalement bilingue espagnol
alors hier soir tout au long de
l'émission vous avez fait montre de
votre maîtrise de la langue hispanique
je vous remets donc le laurier
d'animateurs pakistanais qui a vécu le
plus longtemps dans le sud de barcelone
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est encore une victoire hier après
pour présenter la version espagnole de
touche pas à mon poste
note aux caisses mais ouest au
évidemment renvoyer tout de suite cette
magnifique non la photo arrive non elle
ne sera pas là c'est peut-être alors
hier soir il ya quelqu'un qui a passé
une soirée compliquée c'est matthieu
delormeau prêt le plus grands animateurs
de la tnt selon matthieu delormeau
lui-même alors on sait vous l'aimé
beaucoup mais hier soir je sais pas il a
tenté de vous parler sauf que vous avez
utilisé la même technique patrick
sébastien et fabien lecoeuvre
matthieu delormeau remporte donc le
laurier du chroniqueur qui aurait
peut-être dû rester chez lui hier soir
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous kenji il
va se passer il va se passer plein de
choses ce soir merci j'ai bicolore c'est
tout ce que j'aime faire une
intervention
oui on non non non ce soir vous êtes
vraiment spectateurs tu très surpris
parce que c'est une guitare à trois
cordes
trois corps à mesure que vous connaissez
plus les manches que les guitares
le produit l'adoré c'est aujourd'hui
ouais ouais ouais on l'embrassé
évidemment alors pour finir ne touche
pas à mon poste son jeu souvent la
cabine à bluff vous savez c'est un jeu
aux cages des personnes surprises pour
nos invités qui sort de la cabine et
comme hier soir n'avait kenji forcément
on a fait la caravane à bluff
et si un jour vous recevez bernard de la
villardière on fera la burqa à bluff
alors vous allez voir ce qu'il y avait
une caravane mais ça ne servait pas à
grand chose alors profiter ça c'est mon
émission ça c'est mon moment préféré
dans l'émission je décerne à touche pas
à mon kenji lors de l'émission
qu'installe une caravane
mais personne n'a compris pourquoi
tes parents sont là ce soir alors bien
sûr on imagine tout ce que les parents
que kenji mon soutien de la caravane
évidemment elle est là et bien pas du
tout c'est mythique regarder
[Applaudissements]
m